welcome to this demo in which we are
going to talk about that how exactly we
can create the maven project into the
eclipse here now Eclipse is the kind of
an ID which is available there and
normally we use it for kind of a
software development tool as in kind of
a development tool there so that we will
be able to do the setup and the
configurations of new projects over
there now Eclipse usually used by the
developers to write the source code and
here we can create new projects we can
also clone some existing projects from
the git repositories also and according
to the git plug-in as per the
utilization of that they can actually do
the modifications commits merging all
that activity through the Eclipse so
Eclipse also support other projects also
are the languages also but primarily
it's being used for the Java software
dwell medium now eclipse is something
which is quite common tool in among the
developers among the Java developers and
it also have the extensive support for
the programming languages like Android
where the Java same runtime is utilize
them so it can be used for both the Java
and Android based applications so it
provides an excellent plugin into
Eclipse with that automatically creates
the maven and the eclipse all together
so you don't have to specifically go for
the installation of maven it will be
automatically available there and
automatically integrated within the
Eclipse
now Eclipse automatically downloads the
required dependencies from the remote
maven repositories there
so while preparing or while working on
the source code you don't have to work
on any kind of the dependencies or any
kind of third-party jars if you are
working on a maven project so
automatically the dependencies will be
downloaded by the particular eclipse
here so the maven dependencies can be
updated with the Eclipse IDE itself
because we can edit the pound or XML
file and you can also trigger the builds
custom maven builds also with the help
of Eclipse here so Eclipse Prime is
suppose that how we are going to build
or how we are going to work on this
whole build process there and whatever
the things is available and possible we
will be able to do it with the help of
eclipsed as such over here right so
let's see a small demo on the Eclipse
how to create a maven project and let's
play with the dependencies over there so
let's login to the simple and virtual
machine so now here we have the Eclipse
so we can open that so eclipse is a
oxygen version is what deployed over
here so once we open it so what will
happen that we have to launch it into a
particular workspace so usually this is
the workspace which we can use so we can
click on this one
so it will open the window like a Clips
window ID you over here now we don't
have any project so we have to create a
new project here so all you have to do
is that you have to go to the file name
and if you want to specifically go for a
Java project you can do that or any
other object you want to create but I
just want to create in another type of
project so that's why I will be clicking
on the project here now here you will
scroll down we will be able to see all
the different kind of projects over here
so I just want to go for maven so that's
why I've selected there so I have just
need to proceed next now here we have
two provider that what exactly you know
we want to go for the workspace so we
are going for the default workspace here
and I'm not doing any kind of
customization to that point and when I
click on next here so I will be
selecting ok that I need to create a new
project so this is a particular
mechanism of maven that we can generate
a particular maven project with the help
of this plugin of may 1 so I'll just
clove in next here now here we will be
providing the value like group ID so
group ID you can change but here I can
say like maven project so that's the
artifact which I am trying to create and
was in according to yourself you can do
like this one is there so these things
we can change later on also so nobody is
going to have these things hard-coded
and you cannot change later on later on
easily you can change and modify these
things now once that is done so what you
can do is that you can just click on
finish and with the finish button what
will happen that the project will be
automatically created in the Eclipse so
if you expand here right now there is no
errors as such here so if you open the
palm to XML file you will see the basic
information like artifact ID and the
group ID which we provided but with that
you also see the g-unit dependencies
added up there because it's a something
kind of a mechanism which is prepared in
case of ID that by default it gets
integrated with the j-unit so which
means that it's saying that yes why
default the test cases will also be
created in the J unit here so you can
see that AB dot Java is the default one
like a default class file which is
available there and in the appcache dot
java we have the test cases which is
available there and it a name
j-unit now it's completely your
requirement now so you can proceed with
the creating some class files and having
some test cases so you can add more and
more base over here but this is a kind
of a basic skeleton which is created as
of now just to start the things up here
so these are those initial things which
we are trying to do here and we are just
trying to create a dummy project like an
empty project and later on you can keep
on adding and keep on you know
increasing the source code step by step
so this is a way that how you can create
a basics project in the 'man in the
eclipse here and it also gets integrated
immediately with the Palm D'Or XML file
now if I remove the dependency here now
dependency is very important in case of
maven because if we don't have the
dependency for example I remove this
dependency here and save the file
so immediately what will happen that or
you will be able to see some error
messages related to the particular
j-unit here and that is coming into the
app test or Java so the dependencies you
can add you can delete over there but
automatically due to that the error
messages will also start coming up into
the particular maven project here so you
can see here that it started throwing an
error little change unit because I
remove the dependency of the chase unit
here so all I can do is that I can
actually remove the particular
dependency I can undo my steps here and
do the save again and what will happen
that all my dependencies will be again
resolved and my test cases will also be
successful now so I don't see any kind
of error messages over there
so it's very dynamic over here with the
Eclipse and just the way you remove the
dependencies immediately it will be
reflected into your Eclipse there so
it's not like you have to forcefully go
there and run any kind of maven build
it's not like that so automatically you
will be able to know that whether there
is any kind of dependencies issues or
any kind of executables which is removed
from your maven project here right so
that's it for this demo and this is how
we create a maven project as such in
Eclipse right so that was the maven
project so pretty much this is what we
have and this is how we create a new
project a maven project into the Eclipse
here so thanks everyone for this one
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified click
here